taking the class and walking it walking
into the class in the first day with
Seth and Sarah was an introduction to a
more radical notion but the way I was
excited about a self-generated world and
dreams had really tight parallels in
waking life that this is a
self-generated world and in much the
same way that there are fundamental
rules to my vision and to my audition
that created my world that I am a world
creator as much as a world experiencer
and it's it's not a new notion for me in
a sense but what was really new is the
idea that you could have experiences
like something as simple as a ganzfeld
ping-pong ball experience and then you
could start to see those rules
um they talked a lot about perceiving
perception but how is it that we can
reveal the fundamental building blocks
of our experience to ourselves through
these sorts of experiential experiments
and so the notion that waking life is a
generated dream the notion that you can
sit between logic and illogic subjective
and objective in your day-to-day
experience for me was a really tight tie
and I don't want to take too much time
because I think the talk is gonna be a
lot of fun but that sort of meeting
ground sleeping as the way of seeing
sleeping as a way of seeing yourself
generating your world yourself
generating your visual world your
semantic world using experimentation as
a form of self investigation of those
initial fundamental rules those
fundamentally constructive experiences
and then coming to class and seeing
you're doing it when you're awake too
and you you have to mix art and science
you have to mix experience an experiment
to really get at this intersection was
super exciting for me so so yeah um I
hope you have a lot of fun talking about
seeing internal and external
when I wish all the best and I'm sorry I
can't beat it all right